çok hızlı değişen bir çağda yaşıyoruz bu
tarih için Aslında çok büyük nimet olan
bir çağ çünkü genelde Burada şimdi ben
teknolojiden bahsederek başlayacağım
Aslında chat gpt diye bir adet çıktı
biliyorsun bir alet çıktı Bir sofraya
çıktı bu değişimi daha da hızlandırdı
Dolayısıyla garip gelecek bir
tarihçiden bahsediyor diye ama aslında
teknolojiyle ilgili bir şeyden
bahsetmeyeceğim sadece değişimin
kendisinden yeniliğin kendisinden
bahsedeceğim çok hızlı değişen bir çağda
yaşıyoruz
annelerimiz için radyoyla benim için
siyah beyaz televizyonla başlayan bir
dünyada bir anda Eee renkli televizyona
bilgisayarlara işte iPhone'lara akıllı
telefonlara geçtik ve her değişim bize
yeni challenge'lar yeni mücadeleler yeni
imkanlar yeni fırsatlar getirdi ve
Aslında bugün bizim ahlaki olarak toplu
olarak çektiğimiz ya da ekonomik olarak
çektiğimiz zorluklar ya da yararlandığım
zaman avantajlar bana ne kadar adapte
olabildiğinizi ilgili ve bu tarih için
çok büyük bir nimet Çünkü tarih bizim
sandığımız gibi savaşların sultanların
tarihi değil Tarih Aslında değişiminin
ilmi uzun için bir süreçte insanların
değişik durumlarda nasıl davrandıklarını
toplumların değişik durumlarını nasıl
davranırlar adapte olduklarını çok güzel
görebileceğiniz bir laboratuvar Çünkü
insanın aslında bir laboratuvarı yok
Dolayısıyla toplumlar devletler
kuruldular fırsatlara Krizlere değişme
nasıl tepki gösterir bunu çok iyi
görebiliriz Ben bugün o çekçiyi bitir
artık zirveye vuran çünkü en yakın Ne
oldu insanın kendi emeği üzerindeki
denetimi kaybetmesi sıradanlaşması
üzerinde biraz konuşmak istiyor Çünkü
çekici çıktı ve resim yapabiliyor bu
alet senaryo yazabiliyor Resort propol
yazabiliyor Yani bir makaleye bir Rise
ölçütü bayağı bir yere başvuracaksın onu
yazabiliyor Hatta makalenin kendisini
yazabiliyor orta halli makaleleri
yazabiliyor divan şiiri yazdırdılar buna
Divan şiirinde işe yarayacak bilmiyorum
Muhtemelen hiçbir işe yaramayacaktır ama
ve Tashih yapıyor bu şu demek Nasıl
robotlar İlk çıktığında ya da makineler
İlk çıktığında birçok insan işsiz kaldı
Özellikle bu Salonu oluşturduğunu
düşündüğüm beyaz yakaların büyük bir
çoğunluğu Aslında önümüzdeki günlerde
Eğer fark yaratamazlarsa Eğer iz
bırakamazlarsa Eğer yaptıkları işi çok
iyi yapmıyorlarsa orijinal değiller
bundan sonra işleri çok zor olacak Çok
komple bir iş marketinde kendilerine pek
bir şans bulamayacaklar aynı şey
robotlar ve mavi yakalar için de
söylenebilir ama robotların bir maliyeti
var dolayısıyla bir Hollanda'da falan
var mesela havuç toplayan devasa
robotlar falan ama ancak bu işçi
ücretlerinin düşük olduğu ülkelerde Çok
etkili olmayacaktır hala bu robotların
bir arama soft yazılımın Yani bir kitabı
düzenleyen düzelten musahihin ya da ne
bileyim Ortalama bir akademisyenin ya da
kötü senaryo yazan En azından bir
senaristin işini yapacak sofilerin bir
parası yok bir ücret yok Çok ufak
ücretleri bunları yapabiliyorlar birçok
arkadaşımızla da konuştuğumuzda yayıncı
Bilmem mi Bunların büyük bir çoğunluğunu
yerine programlar kullanmaya tüm
başladılar bu aslında tarihte bir sürece
veriyor Sanayi devriminden sonra eee Tam
da bugünkü de benzer bir süreç daha önce
yaşandı Sanayi Devrimi ilk olduğunda
işte burada görüyorsunuz makinelere
saldıran işçiler diyoruz bunlara Birçok
yerde olan bir şey sanayi devrimi
çıktığında bir anda artık el emeği ile
el emeği değerli olmayan niteliksiz
işçiler Ee kızıp makinelere saldırdılar
neden makinelere saldırdılar Çünkü
daytük harcavs diye saltpark'ta bir şey
var hani onun gibi bunlar bizim işimizi
alıyorlardı aynen o şekilde işimiz
oluyor aynı anda o Tekstil ustalarının
manevra kabiliyetini kaybetmesi ve iş
bulamaması ya da çok kötü şartlarda iş
bulmaları gibi Bugün maden işçilerinde
ya da çok niteliksiz göçmen gibi
niteliksiz işçilerin nasıl Asgari
ücretin altına bile bazen çalışmalarım
da nedeni budur Çünkü işinin değeri yok
Sadece kask koyabiliyor buna benzer bir
süreç artık beyin için de geçerli artık
beyinde kas olarak Ee geçerliliğini
yitirecek Bu da şu demek şimdi bunun
şeyi İz bırak ya genelde bu tip yerlerde
hep şey söylenir İz bırak aslında bir
avantaj kazanmak için söylenen bir şey
değil mi Hani iz bırakırsanız daha iyi
yaşarsınız Hayır iz bırakmazsanız iz
bırakmak bir Lüks değil artık bir
zorunluluk iz bırakmazsanız Eğer bu Ee
yeni ortamda orijinal yani o makineden
ayrışacak bir hale gelmezseniz ileride
Eee özellikle beyaz yakalılar arasında
işinizin çok zor olacağını düşünüyorum
her geçen gün ee bütün veriler
gösteriyor bunu gelir eşitsizliğinde
artık sınıfı yok oldu iş bulmanın
zorlaştığı bir çağda iz bırakmak artık
avantaj yakalamak değil bir zorunluluk
olarak karşımıza çıkıyor sadece iz
bırakmak da yetmeyecek görünür olmak da
gerekecek ikinci bir Kriter olarak
Eskiden biri bir işi yaptığı zaman bunu
takdir eden kurumlar elitler vardı ama
artık böyle değil ne artık diyelim bir
yazarsanız okuyucu ya da bir
akademisyenseniz
üniversitenin kendisi dahi bundan
müstesna değil görünür olmak çok önemli
oldu çünkü görselleşen bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz Mesela bu çok bilinmez bazı
yayınevleri yeni yazarları İnstagram
sayfalarına bakarak alıyorlar bunu
bilmezsiniz pek çok Instagram takipçisi
varsa ilk romanlarını yayınlıyorlar bu
iş buraya kadar geldi ve biz sadece
Kapitalizm olarak da düşünmeyin biz
artık görsel bir dünyada yaşıyoruz Bu ne
demek Eskiden insanlar kitapları mesela
bağırarak okurlardı Orta Çağda görerek
anlamazlar da duyarak anlarlardı
dolayısıyla bir sürü bağıran benim gibi
yüksek sesle konuşan insan görürdünüz
Halbuki bugün kütüphanelerde ben çok
çektim bundan en ufak bir sese hemen şey
yüksek Çünkü artık ses dikkat dağıtır
görerek öğrenirsiniz sadece farklı
olanları da olanlar değil aynı zamanda
farklı sergileyebilenler ortaya
çıkarabilenler şey olacak Çok güzel bir
örneği var bunun Amerika'nın en büyük
başkanlarından biri 4 kere başkan olmuş
tek kişi Frank Aslında bilmezseniz
sakattı engelliydi bir hastalık
geçiriyordu ve böyle cracızlarla şey
değneklerle Dolaşmak zorunda ama
basından gizlenebiliyordu yani Amerikan
tarihinin en büyük başkanı Aslında o
dönem televizyon olmadığı için Başkan
seçilebilmişti Çünkü hiç kimse o dönemde
şeyle dolaşan değnekle dolaşan birini
savaş döneminde güçlü bir lider değil mi
öyle biri lazımken Eğer buna bir görev
vermezdi Dolayısıyla publi
konuşmalarında kamusal konuşmalarında
bir sonraki resimde de göreceksiniz
elini oralara tutarak ya da balkona
tutarak halka göstermemek için şey
yapardı şimdi bu kadar görsel o dönemin
dünyasında görsellik bizi böyle bir
dezavantaja sokmuyordu yani gördüğünüz
şey kısıt dedi bugün Artık her şeyi
görüyoruz insanlar bütün faaliyetler
tamamen bir imajdan oluşmaya başlıyor
demek ki tam da böyle orijinal olmamız
gereken ve orijinalliğimizi yansıtmamız
gereken bir çağda Peki biz buna hazır
mıyız yani diğerlerinden farklı Olmaya
hazır mıyız sürüden ayrı takılmaya ayrı
gitmeye razı mı şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
hocam her yerde yenilik özgünlük kutunun
dışında düşünmek sloganlar görüyoruz
değil mi özellikle böyle beyaz yakalı
ortamlarda daha çok işte yenilik sürekli
duyduğumuz şeyler Şimdi bir yerde
tarihçiliğin getirdiği bir şey bu bir
lafı çok duyuyorsanız bazen de olmadığı
içindir yani Bir Şeyin adını sık
duyuyorsunuz Belki de kendisinin yerinde
Yeller estiği içindir Ben bugün yeniye
en kapalı dönemlerden birinde
yaşadığımızı Ee savunma savunacağım ve
bunun da hiç garip olmadığını Çünkü yeni
kavramının tarihte sadece çok özel
dönemlerde popüler olduğunudan
bahsedeceğim Çünkü tarih boyunca yeni
hep korkulan kaçınılan bir şey olmuştur
mesela eski köye yeni adet getirmek
falan hani hani lafları Ya bunlar ama
bir mantığı var Çünkü yeni Aslında Kaos
getirir Eğer yeninin En azından bir
türlü Kaos getirir Hangi yeğeni bizim
çıkar Siz telefonunuzu telefonunuzun
yenisini isterseniz siz arabanızın
yenisini istersiniz ama paradigmatik
değişiklik getiren yenilikler büyük
kaoslar savaşlar ihtilaller getirir ve
hakikaten
tarihe de baktığımızda yeni açık çok az
toplum vardır batının son 3 400 yılı
mesela İslam dünyası için Konuşacaksak
altın yüzyılları diyeceğimiz bir 300 yıl
gazaliden önce İbni Sina Farabi
dönemleri
entelektüel seviyede En azından Onun
dışında toplumlar baktığınızda yeniye
kapalı Çin'in tarihine baktığınız hep
yeniye kapalı olduğunu gör
üyorsunuz yönetim Nizam ahenk çok daha
önemli Onun için yenilik direkt bir
fayda getirmiyorsa bir iPhone
getirmiyorsa ya da ne bileyim ekonomide
%5 büyüme getirmiyor ki tarım
imparatonda bu imkansız yenilik sadece
başa bela olacak bir şey Hakikaten Batın
tarihine bakarsak yeni fikirler yeni
icatların mesela Fransız İhtilali ne
kadar güzel değil mi Fransız İhtilali
geldi özgürleşip döneminde yaşasaydı
dedim muhtemelen ekmeksizlikten
ölecektin ya da savaşta ölecektiniz o 20
yıllık bir savaş dönemi insanların bir
iç savaş yaşadığı her yerde açtığın ya
da sanayi devrimi gibi bir gün
zenginleştirdi ev Gerze okuyun bakalım
dört tane ayrı ayrı ya da jarminal
filmini izleyin kömür madeninden
insanlar nasıl söylüyorlar nasıl açlık
işte ne bileyim her türlü ahlaki problem
Ee ve ailelerin dağılması insanların
işte sakatlanması bir sürü şeyi
getirmişti Dolayısıyla insanlar bu
yenilik süreçlerin aslında paradigmatik
yeniliği yani bir anda düşünmüş
biçimimizi falan değiştiren yenilik
biçimlerini çok zor kabul ettiler
sanatta Mesela bu da çok görülür Batı
sanatı orijinal niye önem verir ama her
sanat türev öyle değildir
İzleyen var mı aranızda ya da ikona
üzerine bir şey biliyor musunuz ikonada
olay hep aynı ikonayı yapmaktır yeni bir
ikona üretmek değil Bugün de mesela hala
Mimar Sinan'ın camisini yapıyoruz hala
aynı Paradigma içinden konuşuyoruz yani
yeni bir şeyin düşüncesi Aslında çok
nadir ortamlarda kabul gören bir şeydir
Batı bunu kırdığı için ilk başta sanatta
ve düşünce de daha sonra teknolojide
bunu kırabildiği için Batı olmuştur
Sanayi Devrimini gerçekleştirebilmiştir
sürülebilir bir yeniliği taşıyabildiği
için bunu başarmıştır Dolayısıyla biz
işte tarihte O çok eşeksiyonel dönemde
yaşıyoruz yaşadığımız bu dönemde
özellikle 1800'den sonra yeni Tarihte
ilk defa pozitif bir anlam kazandı Ve
Sürdürülebilir oldu Bunun nedeni de bu
istisnai parantezdeki yapılan icatların
bizim hayatımızda direkt sonuçlar
doğurması Siz 1530 da yeni bir heriflik
Bir akım çıkardığınızda bir zındık akımı
çıkardığınızda bu hayatınıza direkt
fayda etmiyorsa ya da dinlerin
yayılmasına Bakın büyük bir yerde büyük
çoğunluk kölelik gibi ya da büyük
fakirlik sorunları çözdüğü için o
Paradigma paradigmatik değişikliğe izin
verilmiştir Sanayi devriminden sonra
yeni bize icat olarak döndü yeni bize
işte aşı olarak döndü yeni bize ortalama
yaşam süremizi arttıran daha iyi
beslenmemize yol açan hastalıklardan
korunmamıza yardım eden hayat
standartlarımızı arttıran bir şey olarak
geri döndü Konfor olarak göründü O
yüzden yeni övmekte bir sıkıntı
çekmiyoruz Ama şunu hep unutuyoruz bu
paradigmatik yenilenmelerin büyük bir
çoğunluğunu insanlar zaten zorunda
kaldığı için gerçekleştirir yani Fransız
ihtilale Fransızlar o süreci
durduramadıkları için Rıza gösterdiler
Fransız İhtilalinin devrimcisi kadar
karşılarında bu Kralı kiliseyi savunan
insanlar da vardı demek ki direkt fayda
sağlamayan yenilenme Aslında bizim çok
ee tarihte sık gördüğümüz bir şey değil
ben bu paradigmatik değişiklikten Korkma
fenomeni yani ufak değişiklikleriyle
Mesela bankasız bir dünya düşünüyor
muyuz düşünmüyorum paradigmatik
değişiklik mesela böyle bu tip
düşünceler hala korkulduğunu Bugün de
benzer bir durum içinde olduğumuzu
düşünüyorum yeni icatlara
tüketebileceğimiz şeylere hazırız ama
zihnimizi bulandıracak ezberimizi
bozacak huzurumuzu kaçıracak
paradigmatik değişikliklerden kaçınıyor
Bu sadece dünya için değil birey için de
öyle yaşayış biçimimizi değiştirmek yeni
meslekler seçme hemen hemen her yerde
olabilir bizi değişik pencerelerden
pencerelerden bakmayı olacak Her şeyden
korkuyoruz bunu en güzel şey de
görebiliriz değişik fikirlere karşı en
toleranssız olduğumuz Çağlar içindeyiz
19 yüzyılda karşılaştırıldığında tam bir
englishy gibi çok basit bir şey
söyleyeceğim biliyorsunuz Psikolojinin
babası önemsiz birimi değil gayet önemli
bir Sigmund Freud hiç yaşamazdı bugün
psik analiz diye bir alan olmasaydı ve
Sigmund Freud
bugün bulsaydı teorilerine iki tane
twitter'daydı tweet'in birinde işte
şöyle yazsaydı Çocuklar annelere seks
yapmaya arsalarlar seks yapamadıkları
için ve bunu babaları yaptığı için ona
karşı öfke duyarlar deseydi ya da
deseydi ki kız çocukları penislerinde
olmadığını anladıkları andan itibaren
bir penis arzusu geliştirirler bu hasret
doğrultusunda bu Arzu doğrultusunda da
cinselliklerini babalarına
yönlendirirler deseydi hiç böyle bir şey
yaşamasaydı Sizce böyle bir tweet
atsaydı Ee psikoloji alanının çok önemli
bir ismi bilimsel değil mi Nasıl bir
karşılık görürdü değil Muhtemelen linç
edilirdi Hayal edebiliyor musunuz Hatta
ben bu tweeti yazayım buraya koyayım
dedim korktum bir kuralları da bildiğim
için Benim işler diye aynen öyle
açan görüşünü bugün Söyleyemeyecek öyle
bir noktaya geldik bakın yakın zamanda
arkada krizinin romanları yeniden Hani
fiyat ayarlaması gibi onun gibi ol
yeniden yazıldı Hayır yeniden yazılmadı
sansürlendi bakın onu bile yazamamışlar
sansür Tam da odur tamam mı yeniden
yazılmadı Ne yaptılar
ırkçı ifadeleri kaldılar ben bakmadım
nedir şimdi bu ifade özgürlüğü nasıl
müdahale edilir bunu toleransınız nasıl
değil Şimdi diyeceksiniz ki ama
ırkçı ifade kullanılmış ırkçılığı mı
verelim
tam Katolik kilisesini söylediği şey
buydu bu indeks libero'nun 16 yüzyıldan
itibaren Siz Eğer bir kitap basmak
İstiyorsanız burada olmayacaktı isminiz
Eğer sultanı Korsanları ezbere
yaşayanlar falan Burada ise bunun Hiçbir
Katolik alamazdı basamazdı ve izin de
basılıyordu şimdi o zaman Katolik de onu
diyordu bunun içinde Allah'a karşı bir
şey var
mı verelim ve bazen hakikaten bunun
içindeki şeyler çok tehlikeli sonuçlarda
doğurabilir Çünkü din Aslında bizim
zannettiğimiz gibi insanların gerçekten
Kaçmak için falan buldukları bir şey
toplumsal hangi taşıyan bir mekanizmadır
ve siz bir katolikseliniz işte ne
bileyim Hali vakti yerindeyse nizamı
korumak istiyorsunuz size mantıklı
geliyor tabii ki insanlar çıkmasın iç
savaş çıkmasın din Savaş çıkmasın yani
işimize gücümüze bakalım vergimizi
verelim yaşayalım
diye düşünüyorsunuz tam aynı argüman
yani hep şöyle bir mekanizma devreye
sokuluyor Nizam bozucu infali yatıcı en
infâ yaratıcı görüşü alabilirsin Bu
ırkçılık olabilir ya da Kristin içindeki
ya da katolikliği ya da Allah'a
uzatılmış katolikli tanrısını uzatılmış
bir dil olabilir bunu alıp bunu
bastırmayı bahane ederek Orada özgür
düşünceye yeniyi kısıtlardın Avrupa
Katolik dünyasının yıllarca yaptı şimdi
gene aynı noktadayız Agatha Christ
romanları bakın Hiç ırkçı biri değil bu
Bu arada o dönemde Kim bana Einstein
seyahatnamesini okumanın daha
keşfetmediler içinde ne ifadeler var
Çinlilerle ilgili bakın o Dönemde
yazılan bazı benzetmeler Bu bir roman
içinden kaldırma çalıştılar açıkçası
Sansürün içinde olduğu bir dönemde
yaşıyoruz ve burada şunu anlamamız lazım
Biz bu Nizam bozucu da tahammül etmeden
yeni fikirler üretemeyiz bunu anlamak
lazım Mesela birileri Kralı kilise
eleştiren O keyif kaçıranlara tahammül
etmeseydi o uyuz keyif kaçıranlara
tahmin etmiyor bugün hala bana alışıyor
yönetiliyordunuz sizi ileri götürecek
adama Oyun Bozan o kışkırtıcı birileri
anarşistler o Servet düşmanlarına onları
susturmayı başarmasaydı bugün hala
Haftanın altı günü 12 saat çalışmak
zorunda kaldık Türkiye'de Ben belki hala
bu kadar çalışan vardır bilmiyorum O
yüzden ama aslında çalışmamanız lazım
Hala bu olabilirdi bir Ufuk açınca fikir
için 10 tane saçmalığa tahammül etmeniz
lazım bir vizyonlar için 100 tane
provakata huzur bozunca tamir etmeniz
lazım Çünkü başka türlü
lütfen
bunu yapamadığınız yerde işte ileriye
gitmiyorsunuz Yani hem rahatsız kendi
bizi rahatsız etme rahatsız
hissetmediniz yerde başarı aşamazsınız
bakın Burası Venedik salam acıyor
Venedik yöneten doç ederin resimleri var
Hepsini çok güzel resimleri var bir sürü
sorudan yapılmış olan ben venedik'i çok
seviyorum yaşadığım için bir kişinin
resmi yok simsiyah bir şekilde bir kez
dokunsun suçları için Eee çok daha
suçları için kafanızı keselim
tuşları için kafası kesilen Ee doç yani
Darbe yapmaya çalışan bir şeyin yerine
simsiyah bir şey var yani Cumhuriyeti
ihanet etmiş lideri seçilmiş Lider ama
Cumhuriyeti monarşi çevirmeyeceğim buna
damlatıyor Memo sınır lanetlenmesi denir
tarihte çok sıktır anasını lanetlenen
bir kişi daha var biliyorsunuz değil mi
yakın zamanda Osmanlı İmparatorluğu'nda
Osman tarla ilgili ödüllerinin isminden
Fuat Köprülü halde Edip Adıvar ve Ömer
Lütfü Barkan bizzat akademisyenler
tarafından çıkarıldı bunları bazı Bunlar
dönemin ırkçı insanları değil bunlar
döneminin büyük Eee siyasal uçlarında
olan insanlar da değil çıkarıldı Biz çok
mücadele ettik başaramadık toplasanız bu
üçünün makalesi Ben de dahil Amerika'da
eğitim almış herkesten daha fazladır Ee
birçoğumuz bunun 1/8'i bile etmezken
oturdular
100 yıl önceki
insanları Ken sıraladılar buradan Neye
gireceğim işte esas kurum politik
doğruculuğun Aslında Merkezi oldu
politik doğrulukla ilgili yapılmış bir
şey var Onunla bitireceğim bizi Aslında
şeye getirecek bakın politik doğruculuk
politik doğruculukla ilgili yapılan
Amerika bunun Merkezi ise bir ankette
8.000 kişi arasında yapılan bir harekete
5 Amerikan dördünün politik doğrucunun
ülke için problem olduğunu düşündüğünü
görüyoruz Özellikle bu oranın Beyazlar
arasında
beyazlardan daha çok bu politik
doğruculuk koruması gereken
Kızılderililer hiç panikler arasında
dağıttığını görüyoruz ve eğitim artıkça
insanların polis şey politik Doğruca
daha çok sarıldı ve bundan kasık
kültürüne daha çok yaklaştığını
görüyoruz Yani aslında eğitim aldıkça
üniversitede eğitim aldıkça çok daha
fazla şey yapmış oluyor çok daha
hoşgörüsüz bir noktaya gelmiş oluyor
Daha endokrine olmuş oluyor yeniye karşı
alerjisi daha ayarladı Demek ki neymiş
biz kendi burcu ve konforumuz içinde
rahatsız olacağımız görüşleri duymak
istemediğimiz için zaten yeniye Hakim o
şey yapan bir ortamda tamir gösteren bir
ortamda yaşamıyoruz fazladan bize yardım
etmesi gereken üniversite gibi kurumlar
Bilakis bürokratiklikleri ile ve bazı
müddam tavırlarla bizi yeniden daha da
uzaklaştırıyor böyle bir ortamda İşte
tam bir yeniliği yakalayamam durumuyla
karşı karşıyayız bitirirken Eğer iz
bırakmak istiyorsanız ve bırakmak
zorundasınız
Sizi rahatsız edecek şeyden korkmamanız
gerekiyor kendinize özgü suyu gelirsin
diye bir şahsına münhasır biri olmak
istiyorsanız bunun zorlayıcı Sizi yalnız
bırakan ve belki de Uyumsuz olarak
adlandırmanıza yol açacak bir süreç
olduğunu unutmayın diyorum Çok teşekkür
ediyorum